By 71-year-old husband just received lab results back showing that his apolipoprotein B is 159.
The rate normal rate is 55 to 140 and I will state that that's the lab range.
Whenever you're looking at any tests understand that there's a lab range and then there's a functional range that we look at.
Different labs when you run different tests are going to have their own range of normals, their high and low range.
From a functional perspective our ranges are typically tighter than that.
This person's apolipoprotein B which is often abbreviated apob is 159 normal lab range is 55 to 140.
That's elevated and is lipoprotein A is 90 and the normal lab range is 2 to 53.
That's elevated. This person states that the question is hard to find.
Although he has had high blood pressure at high cholesterol since childhood he's not overweight.
Should he be concerned about these high latest test numbers?
The answer is well you don't want to necessarily be scared whatever you do any lab tests.
You don't want to make that bring fear to your heart because fear and anxiety what does that do is stimulates your sympathetic nervous system and that can make anything worse.
But you do a test to look objectively at things at data to decide whether you need to do something.
And I would say yes this should spark you to do something.
Apolipoprotein B in your body actually goes on to form what are called BLDL's very low density lipoprotein.
They combine with triglycerides and then circulate around your body and then dump off a triglyceride and up 40 to 40 LDL's.
These are the bad cholesterol portions of cholesterol.
Your husband obviously ran a good lab for the breakdown of cholesterol and fats because most labs that you're going to run just a standard lab you're going to run total cholesterol HDL and LDL.
So if you're going to do more of a cardiac profile then you're going to break it down into these smaller proteins or these smaller fats and even a better lab will even bring it down to oxidized LDL's and oxidized different fats which give us an idea of risk of cardiovascular disease.
This gives us an idea of risk of cardiovascular disease. So if this was my lab and this was my you were a member of my care team, we would definitely want to investigate deeper.
So whatever you have these elevated fats that are coming from the liver you want to make sure that you're protecting this person as best as you can from a natural perspective so that they don't have damage to their arterials.
So this is what can lead to plaque, this is what can lead to damage the endothelial cells, those are the cells that lie in the vessels and you get inflammation of the endothelial lighting and that can block the arteries and it can block the flow to your heart and when you have terminal vessels to the heart you're going to have loss of oxygen and that's what a cardiovascular event is caused from.
So you want to prevent that the reason why you would do this test is to see where you're at so yes, I would definitely even if the person is not this is a perfect example some people think it's oh well if the person is morbidly obese they're going to have a higher risk.
The blood work for people that aren't in that category and all these numbers are normal so the risk involves some familial traits like you said he said high cholesterol for his whole life and there can be a familial hyper cholesterolemia issue and it does presuppose people to a greater risk of cardiovascular events because of that so personally I would not take this lightly I would do make some moves from a nutritional standpoint to
help deal with that. With cardiovascular studies I think I have more blogs on this than I created a number of years ago I would also look at the H. Pylori blog on our website as well because H. Pylori is a major player that is which caused cardiovascular events because it is a major player that causes endothelial inflammation.
So when H. Pylori which is a bacteria that really starts off in the gut is the number one cause of stomach and do I know ulcers it is it can go systemic it can cause very commonly it's one of the top five causes of cardiovascular disease endothelial disease.
It gets in underneath the endothelial layer causes damage to the bio cardio layer layers damages the muscle causes this chronic inflammatory state because it's it's it's an effective organism is grabbed negative bacteria so you want to make sure you investigate for that and basically treat for that that's why I've said over and over again that burberry is probably one of my favorite supplements because burberry
is one of your best killers of H. Pylori and everybody you know has issues with H. Pylori at some point in life and that could be a problem. So yes I would investigate deeper I would be scared this might if you've never had this test before and that's what's good to get labs on a regular basis because if you did have this test before your numbers were worth it normal limits then you want to
you know be quicker to make some decisions on care and move forward if you've had these tests before and they've always been high still it's not a reason to just say well that's just my normal you do want to deal with it
and the cancer is a big thing that we deal with in our clinic cardiovascular disease is still a number of causes of death in the United States and it's because when when people have these numbers typically when they go to a cardiologist they're just given drugs and while drugs can bring the the lab values closer to normal they're not really dealing with the underlying cause
you don't deal with the underlying cause you still have the same degree of possible risk of mortality and at least morbidity from the disorder so you want to dig in to cause and treat the causes best you possibly get even if you're going to still use medication.